you never make good good things pretty
much covered in my talk so I'm just
gonna take question anytime I have
really become fascinated with
interneurons particularly the ones that
reside in the brain or telencephalon and
I'm going to I can be kind of an
overview of that diversity some sort of
idea of where I think it comes from a
series of vignettes of how they form and
give you some flavor of where we hope to
take our lab forward so uh there's some
sort of unwritten rule that you have to
have a Monique all appear in any
neuroscience talks so I'm not gonna
break that and he if you actually read
his works
eg Jones who died just a year or two ago
translated his atlases and they're a
little on the verbose side here's an
actual quote from him the functional
superiority of the human brain is
intimately linked up with the prodigious
abundance on a custom wealth of the so
called neurons with shortened axons it's
a little verbose you can shorten it
basically what he was saying was heaven
compared brains from everything from
mice up to humans he was trying to
puzzle the question of what makes humans
special on good days at least we like to
believe we're smarter than mice and the
question is what is functionally
different about a human brain than a
most brain or rabbit brain and what he
concluded for better or worse was that
what was really seemed different in
humans was both the number and the
elaboration of these local inhibitory
cells and he inferred from that that
perhaps they were something special
about them in consciousness so if you
look at the mosaic of cells within the
brain and pull out the different
subtypes the cerebral cortex hippocampus
and paleo structures are effectively
made up of about 80% of these the so
called principal cells which are really
long range projection excitatory
glutamatergic cells and this twenty to
thirty percent the twenty
representing more what's in Mouse than
the 30% which is more what's in humans
of these interneurons and so that sounds
like a fairly substantial sub population
but these very in abundance from the
fast biking fast get cell which maybe
makes three or four percent down to some
of the really more baroque rare classes
which are some fraction of one percent
and what qahal hypothesized and a lot of
people of hypothesis sense is that this
morphological diversity is reflective of
functional diversity and as we've
learned more and more about them it's
really become clear that these have
unique and interesting functions and the
way you sculpt information in your brain
kind of a simple way of thinking about
information flow in the brain is that
the first thing you do is take the
external world and represent it
internally and that's really the domain
of the excitatory cells but to do
anything interesting to them you have to
be able to attend collect and sculpt
that information with great precision
and it's really these inhibitory cells
that I think carry the weight of that
and as a result increasing evidence I
won't say overwhelming yet but I think
it's coming evidence suggests that when
these guys dysfunction brain dysfunction
follows in close quarters and so
understanding how these guys function
how they integrate and what goes wrong
when they don't function correctly
I think will provide some real insights
into what goes wrong in many people who
have psychiatric conditions so let's
just take a kind of canonical cortical
circuit and look at it for a minute and
think of how information flows through
the brain ascending sensory information
comes up from mainly through the
thalamus somewhat directly from the
olfactory bulb goes into layer four is
relayed up to the associational
superficial layers it goes to other
areas that brain where presumably it's
integrated with other and
nation eventually goes back to layer two
three down to layer four five and then
ever and so irrespective of whether
you're looking at prefrontal
somatosensory visual or motor cortex
these basic layers exist in all those
areas and if you look at them the other
homework feature this is that whether
you look at the input the output the
throughput or the rhythms you see in
areas interneurons are really tightly
integrated into these networks and
they're playing a role not only of
shaping the information but coordinating
that information and what we've
hypothesized and really looked towards
is how do they become integrated into
the brain circuits and how do they
ultimately function in brain circuits
and while my lab is really more
interested in the developmental
questions and as I don't think I've
convinced anyone here really being able
to genetically target in and manipulate
them is going to be key for really being
able to understand their function in
mature brain so if something we're all
really familiar with our various forms
of linkage studies where people find a
gene that they're all very excited about
and link it to some disease and really
one of the things in my point of view is
what can I infer what can anyone infer
from a gene that truly is linked to a
disease and I think probably the easiest
thing you can infer is that the gene in
at least in the nervous system often
functions within the cell where it's
needed and so when we started thinking
about genes and psychiatric disease we
of course were drawn to the question of
is there a Venn diagram overlap between
genes involved in psychiatric disease
and genes expressed in inter neurons so
this is a beautiful kind of overlay of
inter neurons across the cortical layers
done by Robin Tremblay from my
collaborator Bernardo Rudy's lab and
we've over the last five years done a
lot of rna-seq analysis to look at the
inter neurons specific gene expression
and compared it to the other major
player in the cortex the pyramidal cells
the Prince
I really especially in this crowd I was
reading a review by Steve Hyman and go
ping and Steve maccarrol and one of the
the kind of admonishments to the field
they say is you know there's a huge
number of these linkage genes which
become as they put it just so stories
and I have to say if you're really
hardcore about what genes cause which
disease a lot of that's loose but you
know I think there's a real sense that
we're getting more and more high
fidelity in particularly with exome
sequencing and private mutations and
getting a good idea of who does what so
what we found is if you assume the
numbers may be wrong but assume the
ratios may be right
what we found was when we looked at the
inter neurons and just looked in a very
broad way of genes that have been
posited by any measure to be associated
with psychiatric disease we got a Venn
diagram overlap of about 6 percent and
when we tried the same thing with the
pyramidal cells it was about half that
so you know again I'm not sure anything
particularly profound comes out of that
but we'd like to believe and what I
think will be play borne out by further
analysis is that genes in inter neurons
may be particularly genes that when
mutated are more likely to cause
psychiatric disease or said in short
form when inter neurons fail to function
properly psychiatric disease ensues so
here are some examples which have kind
of cherry picked out which are I think
people have more confidence of are
involved in things like intellectual
disability Rhett syndrome or autism and
epilepsy and these are genes that are
clearly from our analysis highly
enriched in inter neurons of course the
question is they don't only function
there and so the kind of game we've
played a lot and expect to play a lot
more moving forward is the sort of thing
where you damage these genes
specifically in the cell types of
interest and see if that causes the
overt behavioral differences changes
that you'd expect to be associated with
psychiatric this
and while we've almost exclusively done
this in mice I have to say we're very
much chomping in the bit to go to
non-human primates and look at higher
species because I think one of the
lessons which again I don't have to
convince this audience of is that it's
really hard to know when a mouse has
autism so moving from that general
introduction to relate the meat of the
matter we think a lot about inter neuron
diversity and how that comes about and
how and how to tell one inter neuron
type from another and you know like many
fields that that involve butterfly
collecting you know you get a lot of
arguments of how many butterflies are
around and so there's the kind of
minimalists and I think I probably
classify myself as more of a minimalist
than an expansionist are the lumpers who
who essentially want to say there are
certain core features like morphology
connectivity markers or or the intrinsic
physiological properties that can pretty
much tell you a class but of course
there's the splitters who essentially
say let's turn a Delhi Delhi menu into
this and make as many sandwiches as we
can so picking one out of the first
column one out of the second one out of
the third and you have one of the ten
thousand different interneuron types you
could perhaps have this is the kind of
argument that goes on a lot I I actually
not sure how possible it is when you
think of cell types at least in the
nervous system it's not clear to me that
you necessarily need ones that can
cluster apart and that you need to
actually put a number of 1 10 20 or 100
on there it's possible that state
changes between inter neurons mesh them
with actual class changes and in fact
the best way for the brain to function
is to cover all the space between them
and so if we're really only kidding
ourselves when we want to talk about
different types that said the Allen
Brain Institute just told us that in the
cortex there are six I think 23
different kinds of inter neurons so
we'll go with that
my point is I don't really care how many
there are
the thing I really want to know is where
does the information get imposed on the
cells how does the information get
imposed on the cells so that they do
what they do how do they get the certain
shapes how do they make the right axons
how do they choose the right Afrin
indifferent partners how do they choose
when and how to fire and their set point
and I think those are all discrete
pieces of information that are tangible
and discoverable and what my lab really
wants to understand is how do you go
from a pluripotent set of progenitor x'
to these cells which arguably have
exquisite and very precise connectivity
and function irrespective of where you
look in the nervous system so I'm gonna
start my talk off by very briefly giving
what is kind of the gospel of my lab
which is an argument of where that
information comes from we divide that
into what we call Cardinal specification
and definitive specification and if I
haven't already previously drilled this
into your head before I'll try doing it
again and essentially it's not an
argument of type so much as where we
should look to get the right information
to understand how the cells develop and
then I'm going to tell you three
vignettes the first one really the part
that's about genetic determination and
genetic cell types and I have to say
this has been an exciting recently an
exciting collaboration both with Connie
Sep Cove over at Harvard and more
recently with realistic teacher who was
a postdoc with Aviv Regev
and I'll show you some unpublished it
and really exciting data that we've got
from that I'm then going to go on to
what goping alluded to one of the things
we believe in what we found is that the
inter neurons in all likelihood don't
have any a priori idea of where and what
circuits they're going to go into but
that's puzzling because if you take a
brain any brain for most any mature
species and look at ca1 cortex first the
hippocampus other parts of the
hippocampus
verse the striatum in each case you can
find a favorite cell type and a favorite
conductivity with great precision and if
you don't know where you're going the
implication is you learn on the job and
we're very interested in how that
learning occurs and we believe that
activity particularly privileged neural
activity in what I guess I'd call a pre
critical period timing turns on gene
expression and alternative splicing to
allow these cells to do what they're
doing and we're really starting to
scratch the surface of how that works
finally I'm going to give you a vignette
this is work that's going to come out
later this month or early next month on
when we've started to look at the way
these inter neurons integrate into
circuits we've realized we kind of made
the assumption or at least I did that
essentially it makes a rough typography
and maybe it cleans that up a little but
essentially the first connectivity it
does is equivalent to its adult
connectivity and when we've actually
tested that assumption in a particular
subtype of inter neurons and really
looked at its connectivity by combining
rabies retrograde tracing I see again
Wickersham who who came up with this
method when he was with that Callaway's
lab and then combine that with
optogenetics which lined up very nicely
with kind of looking at their afferent
function with optogenetics what we've
come to realize is that these inter
neurons actually have a transient
developmental function which seems to be
distinct from the mature function that's
interesting from a point of view how the
brain functions it's also I think really
going to be important to understand how
brain dysfunction occurs we all
recognize that a lot of developmental
disease is developmental and its origin
and we kind of can assume that we can
wait to the adult and see what's wrong
and that would be reflective of what
happened early in development but what
this suggests is that there are these
transient events that come and go and
have a permanent effect much later on
the nervous system and so well you may
think that all your defects are in fast
biking basket cells in prefrontal cortex
if you have schizophrenia that's a
hypothesis that's kind of out there in
the literature what I'll show you is
that it has a special relationship with
another inter neuron type that's
transient but if that relationship
doesn't occur properly the fast biking
cell
develop properly so you may think it's
all the fast-spiking basket cell but it
may be who they talk to early in life so
I think that's a principle that's going
to be important in terms of thinking
about how the brain forms and what goes
wrong in disease so this is taking you
back to the very beginning of my labs
interest in inter neurons what we knew
from the work of smart and Stuart back
in the 50s was that they're the strange
bulges at the bottom of the lateral
ventricles if you took a human brain at
about three weeks of age or most brain
at about 12 days took a chunk of the
cortex off and peered down into the
lateral ventricle what you'd see nestled
at the bottom are these three eminences
the medial lateral and the caudal
ganglionic eminence so they're embryonic
lis and then by the time you get to
birth in a human or even close to birth
in a mouse they've disappeared no one
really understood what they gave rise to
and we some years ago started to use
actually originally kind of classical
developmental biology fade mapping but
more recently genetic mapping to really
understand the relationship of these
structures to the cell types that come
out of them and as you probably have
guessed were already new to these three
structures the medial mikado ganglionic
eminence turn out to be the source of
really all the inter neurons not just in
the cortex but at the campus the
striatum and the amygdala and so it
really puts a very strong link between
the embryonic origin of these cells and
the cell types you're gonna find in the
mature brain and so the way we got into
this was by taking a fluorescently
labeled donor brain cutting out our
favorite areas the lge the CG or the mg
associating them and then using
high-resolution ultrasound backscatter
microscopy essentially just use
transplant methods to put them back in
the brain where the genetically marked
cells could be seen this can be done
without killing the animals and then you
can come back weeks later and see where
they ended up so these were alkaline
phosphatase labeled cells we've done it
with egfp more recently which makes it
were amenable to physiology and
essentially the lessons are pretty
complex but there's a simple take-home
which is that the lge
the lateral ganglionic eminence really
doesn't make any intra neurons in the
cortex it makes a lot of inter neurons
in the olfactory bulb but mainly makes
medium spiny cells in the striatum
whereas the CG and the mga both give
rise to large and diverse populations of
inter neurons and as we dug into this
and looked at it a little more a simple
lesson came out was that when you looked
at the population that came from this
structure in this structure they were
completely non overlapping and so this
really was the first hint that sight of
origin as it turns out time of origin is
a strong predictor to what kind of inter
neurons you're ultimately going to get
and really pointed us to the idea that
if you wanted to understand inter neuron
diversity that's something that starts
right at the birth of these cells as
they come out of these structures so
this is a Venn diagram kind of dividing
up into the different interneurons and
it's kind of like a 2/3 1/3 ratio the
green area are the inter neurons that
come from the CGA
and the purple area here surrounding the
red and the blue area are the ones that
come out of the mga and what we've said
is that you can divide up the inter
neurons into three non-overlapping
categories cge and then somatostatin and
pv from the mga but if you actually get
into it there are a lot of subdivisions
that occur in the cg populations and
more subdivisions that go within the
somatostatin PV cells and so well the
origin gave you a hint of the diversity
that occurred it was really hard to
account for the subtypes that ultimately
showed up within any given region like
the somatosensory cortex or even a more
pointedly the inter neurons as they
differ in the cortex they have the
campus in the striatum so it kind of
suggested developmental genetics and
imprinting on the the progenitors at
Birth was important but it suggests that
something was happening later to tell
them more specifically what to become
and really that that drove us to a
question which we're puzzling
now in moving forward which is how do
you make these cell types which have
general as I'm going to call them
Cardinal classes and embed them in all
sorts of different circuits which
presumably do completely different
things so if you follow it from an
embryonic point of view the inter
neurons are born they're born within
these two structures where they
proliferate they migrate the undergo
this what's called long-range tangential
migration where they kind of followed
the curvature of the brain to go to all
the areas cortex Stratus and stratum and
hippocampus and amygdala then ultimately
they morphologically develop make
synapses and mature and they make these
beautiful cell types and these beautiful
connective patterns that have been well
described in the literature over the
last ten years this seems to be as a
first pass a genetic program that's
imposed on them but as I've already
alluded to you there are environmental
cues and those environmental cues are
tied into neuronal activity and one of
the puzzles is exactly what is a
neuronal activity doing as it passive is
it instructive as it's simply a timing
mechanism and to be honest I'll show you
some evidence for it being important but
you could ask questions later we really
don't understand whether this is an
active role or neuronal activity or just
a possible which essentially when they
get to a certain point activity comes
online and that allows them to wake up
and smell the signals around them that
are going to tell them more specifically
what they need to do so we divide the
inter neuron development along the
developmental axis into Cardinal
specification which roughly speaking is
those things determined at inter
neuronal birth and those include things
like their intrinsic firing properties
their afferent
type tropism what I mean by that some
inter neurons like to make connections
on other inhibitory cells others like to
go to excitatory cells some to the
dendrites some to the axon some to the
soma and finally there seems to be
fundamental molecular markers which are
immutable so parvalbumin for instance is
something that only turns on
spiking cells and not in other cell
types and that seems to be imposed on
them right at the time they're born by
contrast we have what we call definitive
specification which I say is determined
at settling position that's simply
jargon for post migration so wherever
they end up what layer what structure
what area gives them really what I think
is definitive specification and that
really is local connectivity where are
they gonna get connections from who are
they going to make connections to
they're laminar and aerial positioning
and finally which is kind of part and
parcel of their connectivity their
dendritic and exone all targeting let me
give you a quick example of a cardinal
and a definitive specification just so
you know that I'm not speaking loosely
so here's a cardinal specification what
we call fast-spiking basket cells
they're very characterized by it be able
to fire about three times faster than
any other cell type in the cortex their
paranormal targeting and they call
basket cells because they form basket
cells around principle cells and give
large inhibition and they have very
typical markers like parvalbumin however
here's a case where Robin Tremblay from
Bernardo Rudy's lab has looked at basket
cells in layer 5 a verse 5b these are
literally cells that are no more than
twenty or thirty microns from each other
and what you can see is the ones in 5a
get input from P om and send their axons
only to 5a whereas the ones that settle
down at 5b get input from vpm totally
ignore 5a and give projections up to
lair for Sao Paulo or lettuce and some
beautiful work recently which has kind
of shown this in a more experimental way
by showing that they have some intrinsic
character so if you put them in the
wrong place they can back and forth the
right cues but also giving some
indication that they also respond to
where they end up in a specific way
here's another example of one of our
favorite cells of the somatostatin cells
which are in the epic campus most
famously called OLM that means that they
sit up in the ourian's lair and they
send their project
down to like I know some molecular their
cousins in the cortex are called mark
naughty cells they generally sit in deep
layers and send their axons
superficially most classically up to the
layer one and then there's these low
threshold spiking cells down on the
striatum now all these cell types
although they're in completely different
structures share a lot of commonalities
their dendritic targeting the rebound
bursting their facilitating when you
excite them and as we've been able to
show along with Cory Harwell from Arnold
Christine's lab is that common lineages
in fact give rise to inter neurons that
are destined to all these seems the same
three structures so you can come from
one lineage and go to these three
structures now I'll actually show you
that data in a minute so what is the
evidence for the role of genetic
determination and interneuron diversity
and as two extreme models you can
imagine that you have a clone of cells
here and they're gonna form a column a
cluster or a layer in the cortex or
maybe form a part of the ca1 hippocampus
or alternatively you can imagine that
really lineage doesn't predict much and
they get scattered all over the place
and in fact as I'll show you in a minute
the evidence really strongly suggests
this so that's an interesting as an
experimental finding but I think as a
functional finding it's equally
important because it tells you lineage
does not specify their final position
and perhaps even Cardinal specification
is is only telling you certain actual
properties of it but not actually
dictating what structure in the brain
they're actually going to give rise to
so this work was done by a wonderful
postdoc in lab Christian Mayer and
Rachel Bandler and what you see here are
the green cells which represent all the
cells that you just put a retrovirus in
and label but using tricks that Connie
SEP goes develop we can put a barcode in
so that we can recover the barcode and
know with high fidelity who's related to
who so in principle you might think
anyone close to gee each other are
linearly related but when you look at
the barcodes you can see that this cell
is related to this cell in this cell and
so that statement relies on statistical
arguments
the best way I can say it in a simple
way is when we take these pools of
retrovirus and is injecting one two and
three brains and look for barcodes we
often find the same barcodes within one
brain but we almost never find the same
barcodes in separate brains because the
library is so complex that
probabilistically if you see the same
barcode it's very very likely that the
cell came from the same lineage so in
here you might kind of infer lineage is
important they're all in the cortex
these two are beside each other maybe
this guy got lost but then when we
started looking a little more here's one
where two of them ended up in the
hippocampus and another two ended up in
the cortex you might again say well it's
not really that far from each other but
there's a sulcus here these guys must
have got they didn't swim across so they
probably got away from each other really
quite a bit earlier in development and
then we saw a lot of stuff like this
which really kind of surprised us we're
ones in the stratum
central stratum and other ones kind of
on the edge of the stratum and another
language related one is way up in the
cortex so if you do this in a more
quantitative manner and just compare
lineages and each one of these lines
represents a lineage certainly in some
cases you see clusters of interrelated
cells which are closely positioned
together but of course even these ones
that are closely positioned have these
guys that are quite a bit distant from
each other and then we start putting it
in terms of not only distance but
structure you can see that red blue and
green represents cells found in
different structures and here in
probably the most extreme case you have
you know one here in the hippocampus
couple in the cortex and a few in the
striatum so from one lineage of cells
crossing many many structures so at
least a first pass the rules clearly are
not that lineage predicts where you're
going there could be a covert logic to
this which we're still trying to look at
it may be that if as we book you better
will see that there really are ones that
cross structures and ones that don't but
I have to say at first pass my guess is
that while Cardinal specification is
very important in terms of lineage and
birthday actual positioning and wiring
is something that's determined quite a
bit later and so that's something we're
trying to figure out and chase and so
you know the question is
if you have a common lineage that go out
how much will that position of origin
predict morphology connectivity markers
and intrinsic properties so you know no
better place to ask that question than
here at the ground zero of single cell
and RNA seek
we're at the Aviv Regev and Steven
McCarroll and others have done a
wonderful job of sorting these cells and
looking at the lineages and really
understanding the relationship between
the Express home in a single cell and
what they ultimately give rise to so
we've been very lucky in New York to get
Aviv's star postdoc rules to gia come
and join us in over the last few months
rue and my lab with the help of Chris
and Rachel have done a lot of work to
try looking more rigorously at the
developmental interneurons at different
stages of development and where we
really started is looking at those
eminences so we've started to take the
MGE and the cg to areas we know
interneurons come from two areas that
have a lot of commonality and gene
expression and start trying to ask how
do these diverse embryonic structures
give rise to different Cardinals cell
types so what you're looking at is about
2,000 cells just from the mga we have
similar data though it's it's really
just in very early stages from CG in and
LGA where we've taken the cells and done
drop seek on them to analyze them what
you're looking at is the t-sne
projection which takes all the principal
components and crushes that down into
two dimensions and then by looking at
nearest-neighbor analysis using the
first five principal components we're
able to cluster these into different
groups where each cluster presumably has
near relatives that that have something
in common with them and these are the
kinds of patterns we're looking at when
we look at individual genes you can see
that if you look at nest in taupe
to a DLX are ARX electric six or GAD one
all familiar players in terms of the
early differentiation of these cells
different parts of those clusters are
preferentially labeled and that lets us
start to infer as rural Santa had done
in a beautiful paper with a V pseudo
time where we can kind of make some
guess of how they might progress here
and these are supervised where we've
kind of labeled the clusters and you can
imagine that the cells seem to kind of
follow a pattern that looks roughly like
this as they differentiate so this is
pseudo time because of course these are
all cells at one point in time but we're
inferring through the nearest neighbor
analysis is the logical progression of
how they develop from a dividing
pluripotent stem cell to a
differentiated inter neuron we're
actually doing this more longitudinally
now and this is kind of combining real
time with with pseudo time and so this
is where you can take them from
different stages of development bend
them along this and do PCA analysis to
see how they cluster in terms of how
genes relate to the various genetic
diversity within that and then start be
doing non supervised treating petrovic
tree building out a group of algorithms
to look at trajectories and as has been
beautifully pioneered elsewhere but
rules helped us get into this allows us
combining suit of time a real time to
really infer that pattern of gene
expression that goes from a cell to a
differentiated cell integrated in the
circuit and what we hope to get out of
this and I'm going to loop back to this
at the end is we hope to really use this
as a way to start figuring out how the
genes progress and develop into
differentiated structures am i really 15
minutes from the end here it's okay okay
so I I will in real time speed up a
little here so I don't drag you okay so
that's kind of the early developmental
genetics I'm going to take you through
some very quick data where we've looked
at a neuronal activity and here I'm
crunching in a whole ton of expiry
into a small number of figures which
really doesn't do entire justice to it
but lets you get a 10,000 foot overview
in terms of the role of neuronal
activity and the last thing I talked
about which is this scaffolding
transient connectivity that leads to
adult development so I've already shown
you this picture which kind of maps out
neurogenesis migration morphology and
differentiation and so we've become very
interested in how activity might shape
development and so a simple way of doing
that is by taking your favorite inter
neurons and either jacking up the gain
or turning the gain down and we can do
that with a variety of ways either by
doing electroconvulsive shock or by
using channels that either boost the
activity or suppress the activity and
the simple answer is when you decrease
activity they get a lot simpler in their
axonal and dendritic morphology and when
you increase the activity they make more
axons and more dendrites so at least you
can tweak their morphology in the
development this way in a set of
experiments where we've really tried
nailing this down in a more
physiological context we've looked at
the neuroglia form cell which we've
genetically labeled and we've asked how
is activity shaping its development and
so I'm going to really rush through a
ton of data in a few slides and
represents like a whole series of
pharmacological genetic inter
interference experiments in often
genetics so the simple answer is the
neuroglia form cell when you reduce
activity doesn't like it so much and it
makes very small axons and dendrites and
when you start asking where does that
activity actually come from because
obviously in context activity comes from
the afferent projections that impinge on
that and to do that we'll label or
nerdly a form cell with rabies and then
label who projects to it and what we
find developmentally is that they get a
lot of cortical projections we got a lot
of sub plate connections and we get this
big whopping projection from the
thalamus going to these cells and so we
started saying okay that's who's giving
excitatory input to these cells what
happens if we block that excitatory and
put into selective way so what happens
when we take the cortex and by blocking
activity specifically in the cortex
using
tetanus toxin and genetic drivers that
only block these cell types what happens
to the nerve glia form cell and the
answer is not much it doesn't seem to
care that much so maybe that activity
isn't so important well we tried the
same thing using flama blockers and now
we FINA copied exactly what we saw when
we block the activity so what it
suggests is all activity is not created
equal
somehow the activity and pinching on
this cell from the thalamus is somehow
functionally different from the activity
in pinching on this cell from the cortex
and so we started doing optogenetics and
basically now instead of blocking these
cells we put channelrhodopsin into the
cortical cells projecting to this cell
and looked at the NMDA ampar ratios and
got this kind of characteristic pattern
and then did the same thing from the
thalamus and indeed both have NMDA and
AMPA but we noticed up here that there
was a more pronounced two NMDA currents
from the thalamus and even though I
won't show you using pharmacology it
turns out this NMDA represents a lot
more the nr2b
calcium permeate more permeable form of
it so this is not only bigger an MBA but
probably indicating more calcium is
going into the cell so we kind of look
downstream of this and said okay
something important in the NMDA receptor
is going and that somehow leading
through a calcium signaling which
calcineurin is often a part of to the
differentiation of the cell and so we
genetically started wiping out
components of of this like one part of
the NMDA channel or the other and I what
we found is that having any interference
with either these channels or
calcineurin had the morphological effect
but what was most striking and I guess I
yeah there you go is when you block this
this is actually showing you back and
forth what happens in terms of the
connectivity so this is the normal
connectivity but if we in any way
interfere with the calcium signaling
through the NMDA
and then do the rabies tracing what we
found out is you lose a lot of Kalama
can put and that is correspondingly
reflected by an increase in cortical
input so what it's saying is activities
not only just important for the
morphology of these cells it's also
important in helping to determine which
a forensics except in connectivity for
so what I think my postdoc and student
wanted to say is oh well this is great
activity is instructive and I think you
should hold the press on that it's in
there it's important but in no way do we
know it's instructive and I can talk
about that later and I really think
that's one of the challenges we now know
at least in some contexts that activity
is important but exactly what it's doing
we're not sure I also want to add that
beautiful work from leach and low and
unpublished work from Chris McBain's lab
where they've tweaked ampa and nmda
receptors and looked at connectivity of
other cell types
turns out we were really lucky in
pricking the neuroglia form cell because
many other cells when you do these kinds
of manipulations to them don't seem to
have any major change in connectivity or
morphology so again is it a specialized
case that we just got lucky and hit upon
or is activity always going to be
important in the development of these
cells I I'm saying at least in
interneurons I think there's a more
general rule and I base that on the fact
that as we've tweaked the other inter
neuron populations and I showed you a
bit of data on that somatostatin pv it
seems like activity has a generalized
need for all of them but exactly what it
is is something that really we're gonna
have to track down a lot more thoroughly
so this is beautiful work from Natalia
DeMarco as her own lab up at Cornell
Theo Carey honest he's about to start
his own lab in Zurich shortly
Rossi Priya who just got her thesis as
well chef gnome Tuesday mare and she's
going on to a postdoc with Arturo
Alvarez booyah and she's just joined
Renee hands lab so at the functional end
of this we think that this really
reflects two types of signaling and I
have a whole lot of data which I won't
talk about which I'm going to put under
the purview of e to t and e pas coupling
so what we know when we started to look
at how activity is affecting the cells
is that there are a number of
transcriptional targets that are
activity regulated
shouldn't come as a surprise to anyone
who has been in the Boston area and
listen to Mike greenberg talk for the
last 20 years about how activity changes
gene expression and so EDT coupling is
going to be an important part of this
more recently we find a lot of evidence
if EAS coupling were alternative
splicing of these through a number of
specific splice factors in our hands
probably most prominently RB Fox 1 a
gene that Douglas Black has done a lot
of work on suggests that alternative
splicing is also regulated by activity
so in the last few minutes of talking
I'm gonna give you that vignette and
which is I think kind of a warning to
anyone who thinks you can look at the
adult brain and for what happened
developmentally and this is a story
which we have known really formed the
basis for thesis where she showed that
transient inter neuron connectivity is
required for adult cortical circuitry so
this starts off the same way as the
other one you do rabies in this case
targeting somatostatin mark Nadi cells
and look at their connectivity and what
you find developmentally is you get a
whole lot of portable input but like the
neuroglia form a large thalamic input
and this was actually quite surprising
because work from a number of labs of
Barry Conners most prominently was
surprising because the somatostatin cell
in the adult doesn't seem to get much
from a ohmic input whereas the rabies
suggested here it did get big input so
when we did that at P 5 P 18 we did
discover that there were some
differences but many similarities and
here it's shown graphically and the
biggest difference is that while
developmentally the somatostatin cells
in layer 5 6 get a big thought lamech
ventral basal and p om and put that
input drops off by about 90% after you
hit p9 so to make sure this was an
artifact of rabies tracing I'm sorry and
not everyone believes it but I have to
say in our hands the rabies tracing it's
been very reliable and so when we did
the opto genetic approach where we put
channelrhodopsin in the thalamus and
then went up in
cortex and patched on to pyramidal cells
and some of statin neurons and did
physiology at p6 as the rabies would
predict the green line shows you the
kind of excitatory postsynaptic
potential we got when we stimulated the
Flajnik fibers and patch Alonso's
somatostatin cell the black one shows
the connectivity on two parameters cell
so there's something there but it's a
lot smaller what's striking is by p9
this has reversed itself and now this
amount of statin input has got quite a
bit smaller and the pyramidal neuron as
you might expect from the from
maturation gets bigger and if you go up
TP 18 it's much more dramatic so really
this is what you'd expect big the lamb
akin put on two deep layers and layer
four of the pyramidal neurons and almost
nothing on two somatostatin drive so
what about the output of this cell so
you can go down with optogenetics and
look at the next link of this and now
you put a general rhodopsin into the
somatostatin neuron shine light on it
and as you would expect this amount of
statin cell fires and then you go look
at the two cells that it could
presumably connect with the pv
expressing basket cell that's right
sitting beside it or the cortical
pyramidal cell and at P six both of them
seem to get connectivity from this but
what's striking is by P 15 the pv inter
neuron gets an input but a very small
input whereas the pyramidal neuron gets
much bigger so what this suggests is
that there is a change in circuitry from
P 5 to the adult so let's just pay
attention to this one the thalamus is
projecting to the somatostatin inter
neuron and it's then projecting forward
to the pyramidal neuron and the PV cell
but by after p9 this input has got much
much weaker and now this cell is now
only talking to this cell so transiently
this guy gets the lamech input and talks
to the PV cell and by the time you get
to the mature circuit that circuit is
pretty much gone so you know if a tree
falls in the forest and nothing comes of
it who cares so the question is does
that transient circuit where thalamic
informations through somatostatin neuron
to pv cell have any lasting effect on
the surface of the cortex and in order
to ask that we did a simple experiment
of going in now with diphtheria toxin
and taking those normal somatostatin
neurons and knocking them about into
half by selectively injecting diphtheria
toxin in the right cross into deep
layers of cortex in a way that only the
somatostatin cells die and when we do
that and then look at the thalamic to pv
projection after p9 when it should be
very strong like you see here it really
is much much weaker so we've done this
experiment in a number of different ways
I'm just giving one example but the
take-home seems to be if the
somatostatin neurons are damaged early
on the thalamic inputs to the PV cells
don't develop normally now you might say
well that's great but they're also dead
later
is this a developmental thing or is this
a permanent need you did show me that
there is a little bit of input from the
somatostatin neuron to the PD so maybe
that's all that's important so if you do
this same experiment after p10 and do
the same sort of recording the thalamic
to pv cell projection is just fine so
that's a very particular very boutique
sort of example but I think it does
illustrate what I think will be an
important principle that is that there
are transient circuits that change
during development and at least based on
this those transient circuits are
important to the adult mature wiring in
the brain and what I think you can take
home from that is the idea that
developmental wiring is giving a
scaffolding that is absolutely important
for adult brain function and if you want
to understand adult brain function or
how it might go wrong during development
you better study developmental
patterning so this work was done by
chemin impinged a mare helped by green
Wamsley so this is just a kind of
retracing of the experiments I've shown
you I've showed you that genetic
determination and lineage certainly
predicts cardinal types but not position
within brain I've showed a role of
activity in terms of the morphological
development of inter neurons and their
connectivity and finally I showed you
evidence that transient scaffolding is
important for the way we mature Network
forms so what are the challenges moving
forward in and I'm going to put that out
there as a problem of genotype first
type we really want to understand how
the genetic maturation and evolution of
genes in these inter neurons leads to
their wiring in the normal brain and
conversely how we might explain brain
disease when those things don't occur
properly so one of the things we're
really interested is is how early
genetic Cardinal specification force
activity dependent factors affect intra
neuron development a second thing we
want to do is look at the Venn diagram
of genes that are implicated in disease
and understand how many of those genes
which hopefully when validated cause
neurological disease can be accounted
for by their function in inter neurons
and finally I'm going to just show you a
snippet of something that we're really
excited about with the idea that by
understanding the genetics of different
interneuron types we can understand
something about the DNA elements that
will allow us to put things in vectors
like viruses that allow us to target
viruses so they're only expressed
selectively in populations that we're
interested in and I'll show you a
success story where we've taken an
element put it in an AAV and now the
av-express it's highly selectively in
interneuron populations and it's
something we think we can generalize to
target any cell type you might want in
the brain so this is really the kind of
hard work that rules helping us with
looking at any given point in time at
the Selective gene expression in
different areas both at particular
points in times and longitudinal E and
to try figuring out how this gives you
in an unsupervised ways trajectories and
so you know you might see a branch point
here during migration where a gene
expression along a given trajectory
seems to split and the inference is that
there must be information changes that
occur here that turn on those genes in
those selective ways and I think from a
developmental biologists point of view
our challenge is to look at when those
gene changes come on and use that to
understand how environmental in
transiting extrinsic cues lead to the
maturation of these inter neurons in
terms of disease there's two kinds of
experiments which we've scratched the
surface on but I mean really just
scratch this
surface and that is how does specific
genes affect the interneuron function so
as we found your favorite disease gene
CH da what you're saying man that causes
autism or confidence of it if we remove
that or knocked it down which is more
like the human case in just interneurons
would we get phenotypes that were
indicative of an importance of that gene
in that cell type and I think that's one
way of digging in and really connecting
the gene to the cell type to the disease
the other kind of thing which we can get
in there
is by using optogenetic tricks and chemo
genetic tricks we can take our fear of
it cell types and turn the gain up and
down to see how turning off specific
cells in specific areas and specific
times affects the way the circuits
develop so to put that in the context of
interneurons the MG interneurons
although really spread out throughout
the cortex really go into kind of layer
four of layer five six more prominently
and if you think of the cortex more like
an engineer than a developmental
biologist the cortex is really divided
into output layers which are layer five
six input layers which are layer four in
associational layers which are up top
and the MG cells at least
disproportionately have their role in
the input output layers the cg inter
neurons by contrast are
disproportionately in the associational
layers and so you can kind of imagine
from an engineering point of view that
cg inter neurons might have more to do
with association function in the brain
whereas the MG inter neurons might have
more to do with the input/output
functions of the brain so to give you a
taste of why I think that's reasonably
tractable in a conditional knockout
where we've removed a gene called NK x
2.1 from MGE and looked at the mice this
is a mouse where we've only knocked out
about 30% of the cells and KX that has a
very dramatic effect on the development
of those inter neurons and you can see
phenotypically this causes an ataxia
that's probably related to loss of the
inter neurons in the striatum but also
very clear Frank apple FC which we can
see when we do aegs and so this is a
case where you're not knocking out all
of them you're really only knocking
about 30
of the sells out and you get a very
dramatic phenotype let me give you
another example and this is of the CGA
and this is a bit of a cheat it we've
done is use a trick to get rid of
cholinergic receptors on the cg
populations of inter neurons and this is
it's not in every case it's partially
penetrant but it's really striking
phenotype or this ended up with this
incredible you know it moves pretty well
but boy it really likes jumping in
circles I'm not sure how much that tells
us but it at least gives you the first
hint of what we what we're trying to get
at which is as we manipulate specific
interneuron populations how are they
going to impact behavior and and circus
tricks okay finally I'm just going to
give you a snippet of something that's
working beautifully in the lab and we
hope to extrapolate we've started
playing around with various elements yes
we kind of hope to industrialize this
which is why we get wonderfully cryptic
language like proprietary regulatory
element but anyway when you stick this
in an AAV it's it's only about 500 base
pairs put the AAV in the brain you get a
pattern that looks very much like inter
neurons if you basically use this which
is just a genetic trick to mark all
inter neurons reliably and compare it to
what the virus expresses there's about a
93% correspondence of you get about 93%
of the inter neurons in the area of
infection and you get virtually no off
target expression so here you're taking
an AAV trust me I can guarantee you we
tried doing this with free which doesn't
work because even a whiff of create is
enough to cause recombination in a
reporter but if you have something like
a GFP which is easier to see high versus
low levels it clear it's clear that
there's at least a couple orders of
magnitude difference in the expression
of this AAV in inter neurons verse in in
pyramidal cells so if you start putting
chemo genetic tricks here and now we've
put the GQ dread from Brian Roth in
there and then applied the ligand we can
see robust and high levels of firing in
the inter neurons when we patch on
and actually I'm missing a slide but
what we've also been able to show if you
patch on to a pyramidal neuron and put
the dread on even though that virus is
presumably expressing there you get no
excitation but you see a lot of
inhibition which we assume is from the
intra neurons in fact it around it and I
have to say I've given this to a whole
bunch of collaborators the same virus
works beautifully in ferret and some a
wonderful David Fitzpatrick data where
he's been able to show orientation
selectivity of inter neurons in the
ferret this works in zebra finch michael
long a collaborator has looked there and
we're now trying it with john reynolds
in primate and a number of other labs so
I think this is scratching the surface
on what I think is going to be being
able to take us out of just looking at
mice and looking at non-human primates
and other non genetically amenable
species to start looking at how
manipulation of genes so the same fun
we've had for years in mice can now go
into other species and presumably humans
so this is just a thank you slide I've
really mentioned people as I went along
so I'll just leave it at that and take
questions thank you very much